jdbc Java database connect so we're
gonna cover today
what is JDBC need of JDBC data types in
JDBC JDBC architecture JDBC environment
setup steps to connect a JDBC and
finally an example of the jaw of a
database connection
what is JDBC
jdbc is a tool or an application
programming interface that establishes a
connection between standard database and
java application that intends to use
that database
need for JDBC establishing database
connectivity to execute MySQL or SQL
queries and DD ldml commands view and
modify data records
and one of the most important things to
look at when we're talking about a JDBC
and probably the most confusing part
where the Devils in the details is data
types in a JDBC so when we start looking
at the data types and you're setting up
your data you have your SQL which is
your VAR character and your job
equivalent java dot language string and
you have your bit in SQL in Java it's
boolean in SQL it's numeric Java math
big decimal integer int real float float
float so there's no real difference in
job between a real number and a float
number your doubles double your binary
is a byte data Java SQL date so your
date and Java SQL date
and there's also your SQL timestamp
Javad SQL timestamp array Java dot SQL
array reference Java SQL reference
structured Java SQL structure character
Java dot language dot string big integer
long and Java variable binary it's a
byte a club and that's character large
object and then equivalent is Java SQL
Club and then you have your blob in SQL
which is a collection of binary data
stored as a single entity and the
equivalent in Java is going to be your
Java SQL blob now if you're doing a lot
of programming I would suggest having a
cheat sheet there and then once you're
up and running you'll start to remember
most of these just because out of use
with the JDBC architecture we're looking
at the application then it goes into the
JDBC API so you have your application
you're writing your java database
connector API then that has a manager
underneath of it and then you have your
java database connection drivers and the
drivers are the ones that are
transferring that whether it's an SQL
Server MySQL server the Oracle database
or different sources that use a JDBC
connection JDBC environment setup so
when we talk about the environment setup
we have Java and your environmental
setup underneath of that and setting up
a job environment you have to download
the latest JDK set Java to home and set
your Java path so if you're just using
Eclipse for the first time or whatever
IDE you're using the program you want to
make sure you have that all set up and
you have the current JDK in there the
Java development package
and then with MySQL setting up MySQL
environment download the latest MySQL
workbench extract the file run the setup
file and they'll get you set up with
your own MySQL on your computer and
MySQL registers with your operating
system so it's kind of like a global
variable when you start accessing it and
it's designed that way because normally
when you're using an SQL or MySQL
database its installed on a server so it
makes sense that you want it registered
with the operating system so it's
accessed globally
steps to connect your JDBC
step one import your packages this
procedure is followed to make sure that
the relevant packages are readily
available for the API step two load and
register your driver the imported
drivers needed to be loaded and
registered for establishing a connection
between application and database and if
remember in this case we're doing the
MySQL so we make sure our MySQL driver
is installed and step three connecting
database after the first two steps the
next stage is to connect the database
this can be done by a get connection
step for writing a query so now we're
actually starting it into your scripting
here we write in the SQL command or
query that we need to execute if you're
not familiar with SQL it's good to have
an SQL cheat sheet set up once you start
understanding how its put together
you'll find that it goes really quick
and it's pretty fast to learn but it is
its own query language and you do need
to learn a number of the main settings
in pull language so you know what you're
doing
Step five executing query now the query
from the API is executed using execute
query and we'll actually load that up
just as a string variable when we look
at that you'll see how that fits
together
step 6 processing result after step 5
the system basically does two things it
processes an output and retrieves the
values from your query
and then step seven closing statement
the result set and statement needs to be
closed in explicitly and you'll find
there's two closing statements there is
your result set which is still pulling
from the database
and then step 8 which is we need to
actually close closing connection so the
last stage is to disconnect ourselves or
the API from the database so we no
longer have that open connection using
resources so we're going to jump into
our java database connection example and
we're going to do that with what we call
the university database let's start with
a basic overview of MySQL and you can go
to dev dot MySQL com and you'll see here
we can look up more information they
have the download of the newest version
this is a full SQL database package and
some of these you can actually go in
there and if you're doing database
management they can spread across upto
usually don't want to go more than five
servers but it is designed to go up to
five servers kind of set up with
terabytes of data in there for a
developer on the programming side we
usually want to install something like
MySQL locally so on my setup
it says no network connections it
doesn't auto start on the boot up of the
computer and I have it locked down that
way if I use some kind of simple
password or something like that for one
of my demos it doesn't go anywhere no
one can access it now another option to
MySQL is also the SQL light and you go
to the SQL light dot org read more about
it and download it it has a couple
limitations that you're not going to see
in your regular your full-scale MySQL or
Oracle or SQL but most of it will
transfer over and so for a small project
you can actually use it as the backend
for storing your data you can also
integrate it or upgrade it into my SQL
because most of the SQL commands are the
same
and when you go into the Maya skill
which is a significant download versus
SQL light you can certainly go down to
downloads and then there's also the
connectors so dev MySQL comm slash
download slash connector slash Jay and I
bring this up because it depends on how
you setup eclipse for your interface in
your IDE and it depends on what you need
and how exactly on your set up as far as
the connectors we'll look at that a
little bit more closer in the MySQL it
is an Oracle based so you'll have to set
up an account if you don't have one you
have to log in it's all free long as
you're not doing like the enterprise
with all the support and help on it you
don't have to pay for it it's an open
source now once you've installed MySQL
and if you do SQL Lite you're not going
to have these interfaces it'll all be
done from Java code but once you've
installed MySQL it's gonna add in a
terminal window and then also the
workbench which is just a nice GUI
interface for my sequel server and we're
not going to do anything with the
workbench you can play with it certainly
because a lot of times you don't have
the workbench installed on your computer
especially if the MySQL is set up on a
different server and your remote
accessing it especially if you're in the
classroom or something like that they
probably have sent you your login
information so you can get into the
shell quick note though is if you do
your own MySQL just note that I kept
this as a localhost you can actually see
it down here root localhost no outward
connections and that's just to protect
my computer once you start opening those
you have to be aware of your passwords
and since I'm doing demos I want to keep
my passwords really simple so that's not
the focus of the programming
real ugh back in so once you've gone in
there you should have this a lot of
times your interface might be web-based
if it's a remote MySQL connection you're
working with and I'll prompt you for
your username and password in this case
mine is on my computer it automatically
has me log in as admin so I have full
admin rights and then we always like to
start by at least I do is show databases
and these are the current databases on
here they have some different
information on them that is part of the
basic setup and some examples likes
aquila and world are both example
databases that automatically load with
MySQL for this example we're gonna
create a database and it's gonna be
University will do capital there
University don't forget our semicolon
and time you can tell how long it took
point six nine seconds and of course if
we go show databases you'll see now that
there is a university in there and we
want to go ahead and use University that
means that whatever we do any commands
that we have in here for tables or
whatever are now going to be going into
the university database so now our
database has changed let's go ahead and
zoom in let's see here we go sent okay a
little bit more so we get the nice big
prints you can see what I'm doing a
little bit better there we go
all right so we're gonna go ahead and
create our table and this has all been
prepared so I don't have to go through
and redo it all the time you'll see here
we're gonna do a create a table
engineering student and then we have
student ID is an integer not null
Department variable character 25 long
first name last name pass out year
University ranked primary key in
creating this note a couple things first
we created a table engineering students
and we've gone ahead and created the
fields as part of the create set up here
and the things I want you to note is
that
have our integers or student ID is an
integer our department is a variable
character and it's 25 long and the
reason I say that that is really
important is when we flip back on over
here if you remember from our there we
go if you remember from our data types
here's our variable character and in
Java language that's a string a string
doesn't say hey it's only 25 long and so
you got to be a little careful when
you're pushing and pulling this data
especially when you're writing the data
from Java into the SQL that you check
for that length of that string and then
the integers of course an integer and of
course your other data types you can see
how they follow a suit but with variable
character be very aware of that that
that is designated 25 characters long
and we're going to go ahead and insert
some data in here here we go we'll go
ahead and insert into engineering
students values and this is going to be
the student ID and it's also the primary
key so keep in mind that that is a
unique value in there and then we have
CSE computer science engineering Quran
at Korea 2018 1272 so there's our pass
out year 2018 and ranked I guess number
one thousand two hundred and seventy two
I'm not sure where the that's a
university ranking there we go
and then we have some prepared data
which I just went ahead and paste it in
so we have a whole bunch of individuals
in our database now and well I mean it's
the same line over and over again insert
into engineering students values and
then you have your list of values and we
can see that by doing a simple select
we'll do what's the star so it's gonna
select everything one of our hot
characters if you're not familiar with
SQL get a set up on there and look it
over and you can also download a cheat
sheet from somewhere with all the
different commands in there I myself do
a lot of consulting and so I'm always
jumping around from one platform to
another if you're doing that kind of
work it's more important to understand
the limitations and the advantages of
different systems and then you have your
cheat sheets for putting together stuff
really quickly when you need it and you
can see here the data we just put in
there there's our student IDs Department
first name last name passed out year and
University rank we'll go ahead and do
one query in here real quick we're gonna
we already did one query we're gonna do
two queries we did select star from
engineering and then we're gonna go
ahead and select student ID department
first name last name so you can actually
choose what you select instead of doing
the asterisks where student ID equals
102 o2 and when we go ahead and execute
that in here oops
there we go you'll see that it returns
the one individual with that student ID
here
so let's take this back into our Eclipse
because we're dull doing the setup so
you have your my sequel server setup or
you did SQL Lite with a little bit
different setup going on there and let's
flip on over and see what's going on
with eclipse so in Eclipse we're gonna
go in new we'll start a new project and
we'll call this JDBC it's our JDBC
project whoops select a wizard I forgot
where I was going on there it's a job of
wizard we're looking for this project
Java project there we go and we're gonna
call this there now we're in the right
spot
jadi bc package that way everything will
be bundled in there in the same package
and finish it create alright so you can
see right here we have our new JDBC
package we're working with now at this
point there's a lot going on as far as
your options if you set this up for
doing database management which I did
not and I'm going to show you the two
different ways you can go under Windows
and under preferences and in this list
you'll see database management and then
you can just go in there and set it up
this way and I'll pull in that
information for your SQL connections now
if you did not and you've downloaded the
MySQL it does have an option to download
the Java connects which would put it
into wherever you installed that at
which is default under your C Drive
Program Files now on mine
I didn't I downloaded the connection
separately and there's two different
ways we can go under project and under
the build project give that a moment to
come up oops I mean properties there we
go the project properties and the Java
build path this same window can be
accessed by right-clicking on your
package we're working on and then we can
go down to properties and you'll see the
same window opens up and we're going to
go into a Java build path
we're going under library so these are
libraries we want to include in our
setup and then I click on our module
path and at this point you'll see add
external jars here now again if you
haven't already preset up any clips you
can just add jars and it'll be in the
jar library so there's different
possibilities there but I did it down
low so I'm gonna go add external jars
and I happen to keep mine on my D volume
under my SQL and you'll see MySQL
connector Java and this is MySQL 8.0 and
I just go in here oops there we go I
just go ahead and open this up and
you'll see right here it has my
connector Java once I set that in it's
now added those packages and there's
hundreds of actual sub files in there
and it's all set to go and I can apply
and close this window and now I'm ready
to go ahead and start writing my script
and start building a program in here and
let's go ahead and go under source new
and we go ahead and put in a new class
in here and we'll just go call it JDBC
same as the package I'm going to finish
that and we're set up with a new class
in here and once we've got this set the
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and import all of our Java
setup in here so we have the Java
connection and now we want to go ahead
and import it
and when we look at this we can see we
have our connection and remember two of
these have to be closed explicitly and
that's your connection and when you
create the statement you have your
driver manager so when it goes in there
that's the piece that connects to
actually does the connection to the
database the drivers that it convert
everything in the code in there so you
have your connection to the database you
have the code that converts it you have
your result so you're gonna get a result
off of your query then you have your
exception so if you have an error throws
or something like that that's where
that's going and of course the actual
statement that you're going to send
through the SQL Server and of course we
want our job at a bill that actually run
so we'll put our main in there
public static void main and it's going
to throw the SQL exception so you'll see
right here that's what we're working
with
and there's our Java SQL SQL exception
on there so the first thing we're gonna
need on our setup is put that in here
it's going to be our connection
information we need to know the user
name and we're just gonna call it string
you name equals in this case I created a
user Richard underscore simply learn and
then I created a password my password
remember this is a localhost
so probably don't want to have a simple
password like that but Mike this whole
database is locked down on just this
computer there's no outside network
access or anything like that to get in
here
and then of course this is a separate
user so it's not even my admin or root
user and then we go ahead and put a
query right here in this case we'll
start with our most basic query if you
remember we already did that on our at
the very beginning select star from
engineering students and we're going to
use that query in our code to start off
with and then another really common
thing when you're setting this up
is that we also want to test it and see
hey did we import our package correctly
is it set up correctly so remember we
came in and we imported our my sequel
connector jar file in the code we would
just want to make sure it's it's working
correctly and that's what this is it
says try class 4 name and then it has
our com my SQL dot CJ JDBC driver saying
hey do we have the driver for this
that's all that's doing and if not then
it's going to print an error so we can
find out why it doesn't have that driver
and then next we want to actually start
getting into our actual code and in here
we're gonna do a try cuz whenever you do
any kind of major connection you want to
make sure that you're looking for your
errors you're not going to mess on
anything and we're gonna do a catch and
so we're looking for any kind of SQL
exception error and before this demo
we'll just do you know print it out so
I'm hoping spot goes into the catch
section there we go
so we'll print it out over down here as
far as the error on there and it's an x
ql exception so it's still looking for
the code which we haven't put in here
yet and this is really where the the
magic really starts to happen because we
have our connection and there we go and
you'll see that the connection is that's
all this is right here here's our
connection up here and they pop it down
here we have a connection we'll just
call it con do one end so keep it
uniformed
there we go and this is going to go to
the driver so in other words right here
we're going to need a the driver manager
and that's where we imported here and it
says get connection cuz that's part of
the driver manager and we have our URL
let's see and we of course forgot to put
the URL and up above so let's go ahead
and go back there and put that in
and the URL comes out as a JDBC MySQL
that is registered with my computer so
my computer has when it's running the
MySQL this is the localhost in this case
we call it University that's where this
comes from and that's all part of your
MySQL setup if you're working with the
remote database you'd want to get this
information from the remote whoever set
the database up so that you have this
particular line of where to call and so
we go back down here we have our
connection it's all set up on here the
next thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create our statement and
this initializes it so we have a
statement called statement but this
statements going to be based on our
driver manager which is in connected to
the connection so these are all
connected to each other and this
generates the format it needs for when
we actually send our inquiry remember
here's our query right here so we're
gonna send select star from engineering
students for right now we haven't put
that part in we're just creating the
class or initiating the instance so that
we can do that and then once we've
initiated the instance here let's go
down here
we need to go ahead and generate a
result and so we have our result set
again that comes up here from what we
brought in we're storing the data coming
in or storing the pipeline to bring it
in we're just going to call that result
and then we have this is generated from
our statement here's our statements this
is all like linked together here's our
execute query which is part of the
statement and here's the actual query
which is coming that we put together the
select star from engineering students
and then finally we want to actually do
something with our information so we'll
do is we'll just loop through it while
and here's our result set that we just
generated so while result dot next and
this just generates a boolean so it says
hey there's still another result coming
in so we need to go ahead and get that
next result and we'll go ahead and
create a and we'll take that string
University data and then we're going to
loop through the different results there
we go
integer and then here we go University
data then we want to tag on the end of
it result dot get string I so what's
going on here there we just did a bunch
of things we are going through each row
result dot next each row of data that
comes off of the database until this
returns null there's no next result
coming in there and then we come in
there we look at the result the one
we're looking at is the current one so
it goes through I forget how many we put
in there about 20 because you know row
28 1 0 Row 1 Row 2 Row 3 Row 4 and then
on each of these rows we have a string
and it's an array of strings and we're
going to get that string and it returns
I so this is get string of column I so
we have row and column in really
important in today's programming to
really understand rows and columns
because it's so central to most of the
data processing going on
and then finally we want to go ahead and
see our results let's print them out
we'll put in our nice print statement
system out print line university data so
this is going to printing each row as it
goes through it and then I'll reset the
row again to an empty string and then
I'll add each of the columns to that row
from our result and then we'll print the
next row out and now that we have a
complete code let's go ahead and go up
here hit the Run button it's going to
compile it runs it out and we can see
down here let me just get my double
mouth so we can get a better view here's
our different your ID comes up with
there I forget what the actual set of us
but the CSE the name the date the
ranking all that prints out one row at a
time and that's what we're doing here of
course if you're processing the data
differently you might be loading this
into a user interface this might be
generating other information you may be
doing statistics with it but you can see
how it's set up in here as far as
pulling the data into the java format
and then running it from there
just so we can get a quick glimpse of
where this goes let's go back up here
and we're going to flip back and forth
between a couple different screens so
let me do that and here if you remember
we did select star from engineering
students and there's the same thing up
here that we got down here this is our
my sequel server interface and this is
the interface we built in Java your
premiere we also did this particular
selection selects do tonight a
department first name last name pass out
your University rank from engineering
students where student ID is and we got
the single row on here and this is kind
of interesting because I switched
something in the code here where this
could cause a problem
it won't on this one let me go ahead and
paste this in here and then we'll run
and compile this one and you see it
comes out with the single user so the
danger of this particular code is that I
went ahead and hard-coded in a loop for
I equals
one two six and so this one we pulled it
just happened to be that we did selected
six different columns in here so you got
to be a little careful when you're
coding in here what are you polling and
where is it going you'll can see if I
take out oh this do we'll just remove
the student ID and we're gonna run that
without the student ID let me compile it
there we go and it gives us a bunch of
errors because it doesn't see the we're
sure to call them down here so when it
gets down to this code down here under
the while statement and it goes hey
where's number six well there's no
number six and so we get a lot of errors
on that and you can see where our
queries let me just go back up here and
paste another query in there we go and
we'll run this one and we're looking at
is we're gonna go ahead and do the same
columns and we'll just leave this as a
star to make it easy so we're gonna
select all columns
from engineering students where the
pass-out year is 2018 just do a copy of
that one and we'll run that recompiles
and you can see here's all the 2018 on
here if you look at the dates so they're
all 2018 and that's the same as our
query directly into the sequel server if
I do the same thing on here you'll see
they're exactly the same and just
because we're having fun let's flip this
back over here and we'll do one more
sequel server and let's do in this one
let's just take this whole thing out
here
and in this one we're gonna pull in all
the departments but I want the minimal
University ranking as the highest from
engineering students that way we can get
an order of the rankings on here and
we'll go ahead and run this and there we
go there's our minimal one so this one
hit the lowest ranking on there or
closest to number one then we can do
that in here and get the same result
there's Quran Quran is awesome ranking
number 96 and you still there's other
people that are ranked way below Quran
so that's this guy must be super smart
so that concludes our JDBC example
university database where we took a
quick look at my sequel server or you
can do as ql light and some basic
queries you can put in there and how
that works thank you for joining us
today and simply learned for more
information please visit